[تصفيق]
لا اله الا الله لا اله الا الله لا
[موسيقى]
اله الا اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه
اخبار الجزيره اهلا بكم في تصعيد جديد في
نابلس الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن قتلى ناشطين
نفذا عمليه في الاغوار الشهر الماضي
القسام تتبنى وتقول ان عمليه الاغوار
الاغوار جاءت ردا على الاعتداءات في
الاقصى في رمضان وفي بلده حواره قوه
الاحتلال تقتل فتاه فلسطينيه بزعم قيامها
بعمليه الطعن معركه السيطره على المقر
السياديه والعسكريه تحتدم في العاصمه
السودانيه الجيش يشن هجوما واسعا في محيط
القصر الجمهوري ويعلن تصديه لمحاوله الدعم
السريع التقدم نحو قياده منطقه بحر
العسكريه والبيت الابيض يقول ان بايدن
اصدر امرا تنفيذيا يسمح بفرض عقوبات على
شخصيات تزعزع الاستقرار في السودان بعد
اعلانها تعرض الكرملين لهجوم بمسيرات
موسكو تتوعد وتتهم واشنطن باعطاء كييف
الامر بالهجوم
الابيض ينفي وعلى الارض القوات الروسيه
توسع نطاق هجماتها على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
ومقاطعات جنوبيه بعشرات المسيره في اجراء
يهدف الى مواجهه التضخم مجلس الاحتياطي
الفيدراليه الامريكي يرفع سعر الفائده
بنسبه ربع في المئه لتصبح خمسه وربعا في
المئه حيث تعد هذه الزياده العاشره على
توالي اذ وصل سعر الفائده الى اعلى مستوى
له في 16 عاما
الى اللقاء